today in Taiwan people from all walks of
life are choosing to be stung by bees
often dozens of times in one city
show wrong Chen's battling multiple
sclerosis a disease which slowly causes
the body's nerve to deteriorate for six
months I was bedridden I could not move
I would have symptoms of tingling and
numbness in my hands
there was excruciating pain then show
wrong heard about bee sting therapy for
help she turned to mr. Cheng Yi Chen bee
sting therapy master a trained master
who has practiced bee sting therapy for
12 years every week mr. Chen and his
assistants treat 200 patients and
sacrifice 6000 honeybees the results he
says can be astounding or after 600 bees
you look five years younger than your
contemporaries but can be stings really
help show wrong fight multiple sclerosis
she began an intensive course of therapy
receiving over 200 stings a week for
months on end honeybees only sting once
and they died soon after
but even separated from the bee the
Stinger continues to inject venom into
its victim
the body responds with a flood of
histamines and white blood cells and
soon the area becomes hot red swollen
and itchy me once tearful I don't even
have time to feel the panic law he
stains me again and the pan lasts for
one hour
many think it is based on the five
thousand-year-old practice of
acupuncture a proven treatment for pain
although today mr. Chen sees be
acupuncture as a labor of love even he
once considered it taboo in fact like
most of us he was afraid of bees thirty
years ago mr. Chen was an executive for
a textiles company then his wife began
to suffer from arthritic pain so severe
she couldn't cook or even stand up
straight Western medicines didn't do
much good but when she told her husband
she wanted to get stung by bees he
thought the idea was ridiculous
she's naturally is an educated man I was
against it we just did not understand
these but mr. Chen completely changed
his mind when he saw his wife's sudden
improvement after three months her red
blood cell count increased her headache
disappeared I was so surprised I decided
to dive into this mysterious treatment
and collect all the information that it
could mr. Chen vowed to devote his life
to bringing bee sting therapy to others
after six months of beasting therapy
show wrong Chen has seen a dramatic
change she insists the therapy has
relieved her multiple sclerosis and
given her a new lease on life
while most Western trained doctors would
likely say her illness is in remission
Cho Rong is convinced the stings have
helped her walk again it will take years
of study before we'll know whether bee
stings can relieve arthritis or multiple
sclerosis or even the common cold
but whether show wrongs recovery is in
her head or her hands and feet for the
first time in more than a year she feels
she can resume living a therapy most of
us would find taboo is allowing her to
face the future with renewed hope